welcome to the man of recaps this is
bridgerton season one it's the start of
a new social season in london and all
the single people are looking for love
we follow the bridgetons one of the most
well-to-do families in england blessed
with many kids and this year it's time
for the oldest daughter daphne to come
out into society as a debutant and to
make this social season even more
exciting there's a new gossip paper in
town it's written anonymously by lady
whistle down who has a most scathing wit
so yeah it's basically gossip girl meets
pride and prejudice but right now she
has only good things to say about daphne
bridgeton who the queen herself named as
the incomparable of the season so all
the hottest bachelors want to be on her
dance card but she's being cock-blocked
by her older brother anthony yes sadly
their father died making him lord
bridgerton and he's taking his job too
seriously none of these guys is good
enough for his sister but now who's this
riding to town it's the unreasonably
attractive duke of hastings his sassy
aunt lady danberry would love him to
settle down with a nice girl but he has
no intention of marrying he's just in
town for business every girl in town
would love to land a duke but it's
daphne who he runs into with the meet
cute he and her brother are good friends
from college which takes romance right
off the table they get to be just
friends but by now her brother has
scared off every suitor in town and she
might have to marry creepy mccreep face
daphne's not about to let that happen so
now she and simon come up with a scheme
to solve both their problems they
pretend to be courting each other this
will get all the girls off his back and
make the men want daphne even more we
just have to make sure we don't fall in
love for real so you can see where this
is going and their ruse works well all
the boys come calling again daphne
finally convinces her brother yo you
gotta let me date when daphne picks the
one she wants she and the duke can stage
a breakup but for now they have a lot of
fun together now as for anthony
bridgerton it's time he marries too but
he only has eyes for the hot opera
singer he's having a torrid affair with
they are deeply in love but he knows it
can never be so he keeps dumping her but
then changing his mind it's a roller
coaster another family we focus on is
the bridgeton's neighbors the
featheringtons they're not as well to do
as the bridgetons and have three
unmarried daughters that kind of have a
cinderella stepsister's vibe the
youngest daughter penelope is excited
for her first social season but the
featheringtons are hosting another
debutant their distant cousin marina
thompson and she is a beauty all the men
in town are blowing up her dms but she
has a secret oh she's pregnant knocked
up by her soldier boyfriend who went off
to war so now to avoid a scandal they
have to marry her off immediately to an
ugly old lord who's not good at math but
she has one last hope a suitor that
might propose quickly young colin
bridgerton now penelope became good
friends with her cousin but she has a
huge crush on her neighbor colin and
colin likes her too but caesar only has
a friend penelope's best friend is
eloise bridgertin who doesn't want to be
a fancy lady she wants to be a strong
independent woman she admires lady
whistle down and makes it her goal to
find out her real identity and the queen
is also a huge fan of whistle down it's
like hey if you find out you tell me now
there's a lot of pressure on the
firstborns the middle kids not so much
benedict bridgerton wants to be an
artist so he befriends an artist and
starts going to wild artist parties here
he meets madame de la croix the best
modist in the city who makes all the
ladies fancy dresses but turns out she's
not really french and these two start a
torrid affair now back to daphne and the
duke since he hasn't proposed yet she's
still single and all the suitors are
lining up but none of them are quite up
to snuff but now who's this come to
london a prince from prussia that's even
better than a duke he takes a liking to
daphne but she's weirdly not interested
because you guessed it she and the duke
fell in love for real yeah with romance
off the table their friendship really
blossomed and the sexual tension is off
the charts but wait if he likes her why
can't they get married well he has a
tragic backstory his father was an awful
man who showed him no love didn't care
about him as a son just wanted an heir
so on his deathbed he made his father a
sacred bow he would never marry or have
kids so the hastings line would end so
now instead of pretending to be in love
he is in love but is pretending not to
be and daphne's heartbroken but it's
like whatever bro you're lost i'm gonna
marry a prince but when the prince is
gonna propose daphne runs off she and
simon have an argument in the gardens
where they realize wait we're alone and
unchaperoned and oh yeah they start
making out if anyone were to see them
her honor would be ruined forever and
indeed brother anthony's here and none
too pleased it's like bro you defiled my
sister the only way to make it right you
gotta propose right now but he still
committed to never marry so the only way
to make it right is a duel pistols at
dawn but daphne rides out to stop it yo
you boys are being dumb would you
seriously rather get shot than marry me
finally simon explains part of the truth
look i can never have kids so i would
rather die than put you through the
horror of being married without children
it's like yo sure i want kids but i
don't need kids and it's a moot point
anyway because another girl saw us in
the garden you have to marry me or my
honor is ruined so they're gonna be
married but it's not happy because the
duke feels guilty he's trapped her here
and is now distant and to avoid a
scandal they need to get married quickly
which requires special permission from
the queen who was shipping daphne with
the prince so now to convince her they
need to pretend they're madly in love
even though they are madly in love but
pretending not to be so they have their
wedding but it's not a happy occasion
and daphne leaves her family for a
lifetime trapped in a loveless marriage
on their way to his castle they stop at
an inn where he got them separate rooms
and finally they have it out why do you
hate me so much but he's like daphne i
don't hate you i burn with passion for
you and she's like yo bro me too and so
is the moment we've all been waiting for
the duke's glorious abs so daphne and
the duke get it on and you think the
camera's gonna cut away but it doesn't
and indeed as the honeymooners make it
home they are insatiable this show knows
what you want and they spend a whole
episode just doing it in every room in
the castle but every time at the end the
duke pulls out and daphne doesn't
understand why it's not appropriate for
ladies to speak of such lurid things
they teach abstinence-only sex education
so it's up to daphne's ladies maid to
give her the talk about the birds and
the bees and now she realizes it's not
that the duke can't have kids it's that
he won't have kids so in their next
session daphne gets on top and when he's
gonna finish she doesn't get off she's
like yo duke it's not okay that you were
lying to me and he's like yo this is not
okay you abused my reproductive freedom
so now the happy couple are once again
unhappy now back in london colin
bridgeton is falling in love with miss
marina thompson but she needs that
proposal asap she makes a plan to get
him alone where he'll give into
temptation and compromise her so they'll
have to get married quick but oh colin's
too good of a guy he wouldn't do that to
her but he proposes anyway it's like
we're in love why wait and this is great
news of course but marina does really
like him now and feels bad for lying to
him and so the happy couple announces
their engagement to the dismay of poor
penelope but what's this somehow lady
whistle down has uncovered the secret of
her pregnancy breaking off their
engagement and breaking both of their
hearts the fallout hits the whole
featherington family they are now social
pariahs and turns out this isn't even
the featherington's biggest problem
earlier their one daughter had a perfect
match but lord featherington denied it
for no reason turns out he has a
horrible gambling problem and has
gambled away all the girls dowries duke
simon by the way has a best friend who's
a boxer and now featherington approaches
him like hey man take a fall we'll both
get rich and he's gonna do it for his
family so featherington bets everything
he has left with some shady characters
and indeed the boxer takes the fall yes
his money problems are solved as for
miss thompson daphne takes pity on her
and helps her track down her soldier
boyfriend's brother unfortunately her
boyfriend died in combat but the
honorable thing is for him to marry her
and it's like yeah you're hot i don't
mind so it's worked out pretty good
except marina doesn't know this guy but
how did lady whistle down uncover such a
scandal the time has come to unmask this
menace eloise doubles her efforts
bringing in her friend penelope to help
her first theory is that whistle down's
a servant because they hear everything
and go unnoticed problem is they're too
busy actually working all day to write a
gossip column her next theory is that
it's some sort of trades person who
ladies gospel around without thinking
and when she meets her brother's new
girlfriend the seamstress she realizes
madame de la croix is the perfect
candidate eloise wanted to discover who
whistled down was but doesn't want to
unmask her it's like yo girl your
secret's safe with me in fact when she
hears the queen's got her cornered she
runs to warn her of the trap so now back
to the duke and duchess of hastings as
the best match of the season it's their
job to throw the end of season party
they've been trying to talk their issues
out simon tells her about his vow to his
father but she's like oh so you hate
your father more than you love me so
once again they must deceive the town by
pretending to be in love even though
they are in love but pretending not to
be which made them fall in love in the
first place and as they're having their
dance it starts to rain which is a
beautiful cleansing moment they both
realize they've been dumb so the
lovebirds are back together and this
time it's his choice not to pull out and
in the epilogue these two have a
beautiful baby together they get there
happily ever after so happy in fact the
duke is not returning next season their
story's over season two will focus on
the other characters marina thompson is
marrying sir philip crane which is a
good match but it's weird to marry your
dead boyfriend's brother now colin
bridger tin single again penelope
featherington can shoot her shot but
colin's pretty heartbroken he's leaving
town gonna travel abroad to clear his
head and just now returning home from
abroad is francesca burgerton so watch
out for her things are looking up for
the featheringtons until lord
featherington's accosted by the shady
characters who kill him and steal all
his cash should have put it in crypto
bro the antiquated inheritance laws
don't pass as a state to his daughters
it goes to the closest male heir who
apparently is someone interesting and as
for lord anthony bridgeton he still
loves his opera singer they can't keep
their hands off each other finally he's
like you know what screw propriety i
love you and want to be with you but
she's moved on she's now dating the
crimes of grindelwald it's like look man
i love you but i can't do this roller
coaster anymore you gotta let me go for
good and so in season two it'll be time
for anthony to find a wife and he's
resolved to leave love out of the
equation it will also be eloise's turn
to come out in society which she's
dreading and about lady whistle down she
learns madame de la cua had an alibi
that night it couldn't be her so who is
the mysterious lady whistle down oh it's
penelope fellerington yes the
intelligent debutant that no one pays
attention to but is carefully watching
everyone else and that's where bridgeton
season one comes to an end
if you like this recap hit that
subscribe button for more of the best
recaps of tv and movies
[Music]